just standing there for me what I've
seen so far has been horrifying so I'm
scared to death of what I'm gonna find
in this kitchen
what's that there
Jesus Christ Almighty
and it's just slime [__] you know what
does that mean when it's slime
bad yeah that's right sticky [__]
disgusting
one two three four five freezers and
this is what you call Fresh Food right
lately at the frizz everything it was
just looking what are we actually
cooking here
what is that
chicken
look at it feel it hold it freezer burn
it's dry it's it's gone
yeah
it's not a [__] loofah for your back
there's the bacon oh my Lord
you are [__] kidding me
jambalaya
are we really in New Orleans come on
garbage
right time to take the family
from Italian who's hungry oh yes let's
go this disguise pays homage to one of
my favorite comedies stinks the National
Lampoon Vacation movies
[Music]
great hopefully our meal is less
disastrous than some of the vacations oh
man
here we go
how are you hey
sure right this way when you walk into
Bella Gianna's your first instinct is to
walk right back out so come on table 23
please I'm sorry 43. how depressing is
this
the tacky decor and the uninviting staff
makes you feel immediately unwelcome you
need a few minutes or are you ready no
uh no what nope we're ready nope we need
a few minutes okay can we order uh
we've ordered a variety of classic
Italian dishes and spaghetti meatballs
very good I'll be right back thank you
if you can't do these staples properly
fried calamani baked Lambs chop first
then a family [__] salad you have no
business being in the restaurant
business I have the two appetizers yeah
go ahead go for it so this is that's the
big clams take one and say a prayer
let's see what I've got in mind then
are really salty I know it tastes like
I'm eating just breadcrumbs
so plan with no clam did you get a plan
calamari is rugby it's not even crispy
they taste old if you like I can give
you a little on each of your dish if you
want these clams are horrendous okay
there is not a clam okay here I'd be
more than happy to take them off the
track there you got it
whatever he wants
hello yes clams sucked
okay I got Glenn sucked my sister sucks
it's better stop
because it's [__] [__] you hear
that shouting don't don't clams in the
clams no nothing there's no clam okay
whatever that's what it is the whole
[__] thing yeah I know yeah okay rip
it up you can cook yourself yeah cook
yourself yeah I know because I'm the one
saying this I'm making it up yeah I know
salad
salad is appalling
Paul is dead don't eat the dressing
smell like the backseat of my car
spaghetti meatballs eggplant parm
so let's say a little prayer for the
entrees
may we not end up
in the ER thank you
that's horrendous
down that looks like the inside of my
grandfather's Underpants that looks like
a placenta I would not feed this to my
dog I would do it this is horrendous
dear tremendous meaning you want me to
take it away you didn't like it here it
was horrible okay great honey take it
away Daniel please you know what if you
like
the whole bit is on me enjoy okay okay
well you don't have to be nasty dear you
don't like anything you don't have to be
nasty I'm not nasty at all dear
thank you wow is he always like that
she always she's always angry
oh my God it's like they're scared of
him hey said the veal's soft the
eggplant soft they're sucked everything
sucks so it's [__] [__] I'm done
so [__] done it's [__] [__]
see in a minute
oh please
where's Daniel you know what why don't
you buy them coffee and dessert too so
they complain about that too tell them
it's on me everything because our food
sucks because it's [__] [__] all
right
oh man that place looks like a dude with
a paint now yeah the farmers I'm with
are locals which should help me maintain
my cover hey there how are y'all but
after spotting the Hideous Decor I'm
feeling a tad over Dressed Man
I don't know what it is but it's some
stank
my feet are sticking to the [__]
carpet have I just stepped enforcement
holy [__]
let's test drive the filet mignon that's
the best I have to offer meat and taters
what's a tater a tater
potato potato
we're ordering menu items that should be
Southern Staples let me get the bowl
how's it going bro the fried oysters can
I get a side pork chop I'm gonna try the
uh fried catfish Malone the large filet
time to flounder um
being locals here would you come here we
quit coming here about three years ago
bring me your appetizers are up
[Music]
thank you
catch the day Hepatitis B
catfish for my powder
of course you'd think the catfish would
be exceptional wouldn't you oh that is
terrible
oh that's horrible right there man
that's not good I'm gonna get changed
okay so just uh just try and attempt to
eat what are you doing because I'm not
real sure how long I can keep eating
this city
there's something you should know my
team has been coming to this restaurant
undercover for quite some time to find
out what is really going on I'd like all
of you to take a look of what I
discovered whilst my team were
Undercover
please pay attention all of you
fashion we know only had 10 people all
week I made more money when I was
[__] 16. in the kitchen it smells
like it has a smell
oh my God what is wrong with you
oh my God
don't laugh it's not funny what I saw in
the video was disgusting I couldn't
believe I ate there it was just it was
gross I wanted I wanted to puke
blaming everything on me well why is why
is this business going down in the Ducks
everyone blames me I'm sick of it oh
come on then he loses the top of the
place it becomes our frenzy [__]
asinine the whole kitchen's [__] it's
scumbag [__] [__] jerkaline
[__] you I'm [__] stuck here
destroying money this is what you wanted
this is what you're doing it's my dream
I [__] everybody I live with that
every day
unfucking believable
let me tell you something
even though it may appear that all of
you have given up maybe I'm bitter
hateful and disgusted inside and it
shows but I never gave up don't
don't it's disgusting Behavior Vinnie
Jeffrey you ever feel your father every
day
did you I'm asking you a question
my father died 20 years ago
okay I'm very sorry for that because Dad
and Mom mean everything to me if if
the right way we feel good about every
day going to work if would you if I'm
asking you a question
when does this kitchen get clean we
don't do deep cleaning we didn't do that
[__] terrible
I've got no dates on here I've got no
[__] reference who leaves these
potatoes in there like that I'm
interested in everything your kitchen's
a war zone can be a long night
what in the [__] is going on in here on
Monday we cooked uh three-time man of
wings we needed would you eat that no
is that the powdered gravy yes just
taste that that's what's going on top of
the shepherd's pie shepherd's pie my ass
Shepherd's shite it tastes like airplane
food look at that
do you have any idea how long that's
gonna sit in there to get like that
what'd you do with that I don't know but
do you have any idea of the thousands of
dollars on the menu you're throwing out
yeah you're right this business is
hemorrhaging
and it starts from right in here
you can do better than this and you too
you don't have to be a top executive
chef to realize how bad this is
functioning I see it so Fred you've been
running this place why would you make
the business so dysfunctional to be
honest with you I want to be I want to
be out of a business but I just kept
coming in out not focusing enough on it
better get your [__] together
Gabby I want all your team in here now I
don't want this [__] place absolutely
spotless
I feel shocked like wake up what are you
doing Fred makes the decision so we get
lazy I think I'm becoming a loser and I
don't want to be a loser
foreign